[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous vous regardez
l'échiquier mondial sur rt français au
sommaire aujourd'hui la biélorussie ou
la réélection d'alexandre loukachenko
pour un sixième mandat consécutif
provoque un soulèvement populaire sans
précédent
alors où en est on aujourd'hui dans ce
bras de fer entre le président
biélorusse et ses opposants
le 22 novembre une nouvelle
manifestation a lieu à miss et dizaines
de milliers de personnes défilent dans
les rues de la capitale exigent la tenue
de nouvelles élections présidentielles
pour sa part le président biélorusse
n'exclut pas l'organisation d'un nouveau
scrutin mais après un référendum sur la
nouvelle constitution dont les délais
restent encore floues la principale
figure de l'opposition biélorusse but la
nati canucks callas appel depuis son
exil lituanien a renforcé la pression
internationale sur loukachenko l'appel
est entendu en union européenne et aux
états unis qui ont décidé de ne pas
reconnaître les résultats du scrutin et
ont adopté des sanctions personnelles
contre alexandre lukashenko ainsi que
plusieurs hauts responsables politiques
pourtant la plupart des états de
l'ancienne urss ainsi que la chine la
turquie et le venezuela ont félicité le
cacher on court après sa réélection
la russie alliée de longue date annonce
un soutien financier et promet d'aider à
stabiliser la situation aussi celle ci
devait dégénérer en biélorusse alexandre
loukachenko a accueilli le soutien avec
gratitude
mais le mystère plane toujours sur ses
réelles intentions politiques
[Musique]
avant de poursuivre à voici un bref
portrait du président biélorusse au
pouvoir depuis plus d'un quart de siècle
c'est le blick
né en 1954 dans le village de copines ça
laisse de la république socialiste
soviétique de biélorussie lukashenko
suit une formation de professeur
d'histoire à l'université pédagogique de
moguilev pourtant une fois son service
militaire terminée il démarre sa
carrière dans l'agriculture et étudie
l'économie agro-industriel à gorki
parallèlement il grimpe les échelons du
parti communiste biélorusse
en 1990 il est élu au parlement où il
est nommé trois ans plus tard pour
diriger une commission de lutte contre
la corruption
ce poste lui servira de tremplin pour la
présidentielle de 1994 qui le remporte
après s'être installé dans le siège du
chef de l'état à loukachenko étend les
pouvoirs présidentiels
il ya des référendums en 1995 et 1996
plus tard il ira plus loin et supprimera
toute limitation des mandats
lors d'un référendum en 2004 s'inspirant
du modèle socialiste
il prône un rôle très fort de l'état
dans l'économie la gratuité des services
publics et le plein emploi à
l'international loukachenko est partisan
d'une ligne politique multivectorielle
d'un côté l'amitié avec la russie
l'allié historique de la biélorussie et
son principal partenaire commercial et
de l'autre une coopération étroite avec
la chine est la normalisation des
relations avec l'occident
et si les relations sino biélorusse se
développe dans quasiment tous les
domaines le partenariat avec l'union
européenne et les etats unis s'essouffle
petit à petit
officiellement lukashenko est élu avec
environ 80% des voix
cependant ce score est contestée par
l'opposition et plusieurs observateurs
indépendants qui ont la certitude que
cette fois ci le décompte des voix a
connu des trucages sans précédent de
semaine en semaine les manifestations
perdent 1 intensité mais les
arrestations et les heurts avec les
forces de police spéciales continuent
lukashenko temps de calmer la foule
n'excluant pas l'organisation d'un
nouveau scrutin
souhaite la nati k9 sky a reconnu par
certains pays comme le nouveau chef de
l'état biélorusse appelle la communauté
internationale à renforcer la pression
sur son adversaire son appel est entendu
par les etats-unis et l'union européenne
ces derniers ne reconnaissent pas non
plus l'issue du scrutin et adapte des
sanctions contre les autorités de minsk
au contraire la plupart des états de
l'ancienne urss la chine ou la turquie
félicite loukachenko pour sa victoire
la russie elle va jusqu'à octroyer une
aide financière à la biélorussie et
promet au cas où de lui apporter son
soutien afin de stabiliser la situation
dans le pays s'est appuyé pourrait-il
donner un nouvel élan à l'intégration
russo biélorusse alors quelle est la
vraie ampleur de la crise politique
actuelle en biélorussie quelles
solutions s'offrent aujourd'hui à
loukachenko dans son propre pays et
comment les récents événements vont-ils
affecter la ligne politique du pays à
l'international pour répondre à toutes
ces questions nous rejoignons pierre
leur un écrivain et spécialiste du monde
post soviétique et de la russie monsieur
leur un bonjour bonjour on peut
constater que les manifestations
biélorussie d'une grande envergure au
début semble se calmer aujourd'hui selon
vous quelles en sont les raisons
principales
cette révolte at elle enfin un avenir
alors les raisons principales la
première c'est la lassitude
on ne peut pas maintenir une pression
politique pendant des semaines et des
semaines
d'autant plus que la répression est
intense qu'il y à beaucoup
d'arrestations c'est à dire des
interpellations les gens sont relâchés
pour la plupart très vite mais cela crée
tout même des difficultés pour ceux qui
manifestent
c'est pourquoi l'opposition a mis au
point une autre stratégie qui est de
d'éviter les grands rassemblements pour
privilégier des petits rassemblements
locaux dans certains quartiers et cetera
ce qui rend beaucoup plus difficile à la
police d'intervenir rapidement et donc
il est
permis pour eux de penser qu'il y aura
une continuité dans les manifestations
sans compter bien entendu que l'hiver
est là et que c'est beaucoup plus
difficile pour les gens de sortir
manifester quand il fait très beau et le
cas cenco promet de céder le pouvoir
après le référendum sur la constitution
vous pensez que c'est un tour de
passe-passe de sa part vous ce sont des
réelles intentions
alors c'est là qu'il faut être il faut
faire une analyse très fine ce qu'a dit
lukashenko c'est que avec la
constitution actuelle et des pouvoirs
très fort pour le président il n'était
pas raisonnable de laisser n'importe qui
n'importe quel politicien parvenir au
pouvoir donc la constitution va être
changé c'est vraisemblablement les
pouvoirs du président dont être réduit
donc devenir un président ou du moins
resté un président avec des pouvoirs
réduits
ce n'est pas forcément à les intentions
de monsieur loukachenko donc je pense
qu'il dit vrai quand il dit qu'il se
retirerait de la présidence
maintenant ce qui est important de
savoir c'est où va aller le véritable
pouvoir est le véritable pouvoir ça peut
être un premier ministre fort et
peut-être que c'est là que l'on
retrouvera monsieur lukashenko après la
réforme constitutionnelle
merci beaucoup monsieur laurent nous
allons poursuivre notre analyse tout de
suite mais nous retrouverons en fin
d'émission pour plus de détails sur la
question merci encore le 22 novembre
pour le 16e dimanche consécutif des
dizaines de milliers de manifestants
défilent dans les différents quartiers
de minsk brandissant des pancartes
réclamant la démission du président
lukashenko certains d'entre eux
descendent sur la chaussée et bloquent
la circulation
face à la foule un important dispositif
de sécurité est déployé des policiers et
des véhicules blindés et des canons à
eau
plus de 200 arrestations ont lieu ce
jour là pourtant l'ampleur actuelle des
manifestations n'est pas la même
qu'au début de la contestation elle
démarre le 9 août jour de la
présidentielle qui a été remportée selon
la commission électorale centrale par le
président alexandre loukachenko avec 80
1,1 pour cent des voix pendant les
semaines qui suivent des centaines de
milliers de personnes descendent dans la
rue accusant les autorités de fraude
électorale massive
lukashenko ordonne la dispersion des
foules avec fermeté bilan plusieurs
morts des centaines de blessés et des
milliers d'arrestations parmi eux les
responsables de mouvements politiques
d'organisations syndicales mm des
journalistes et même si aujourd'hui la
contestation s'essouffle peu à peu la
principale figure de l'opposition
biélorusse fait la nati canoë-kayak
n'entendent pas baisser les bras et
cherche à tout prix à attiser la
contestation depuis son exil en lituanie
où elle est partie en août après un
interrogatoire en biélorussie et l'appel
à une grève générale pose un ultimatum à
loukachenko et exhorte même la
communauté internationale de tai
connecter la biélorussie du système des
changes interbancaire swift en plus tu
ikanos callas initie en août la création
du conseil de coordination organe censé
préparer la transition du pouvoir et
compte à ce jour une soixantaine de
membres parmi lesquels des experts et
des représentants de la société civile
néanmoins loukachenko n'a pas que des
détracteurs dans son propre pays et ses
soutiens à lui se mobilisent aussi le 16
août au moins cinquante mille personnes
selon les autorités se rassemblent sur
la place de l'indépendance brandissant
les drapeaux nationaux et scandant des
slogans pro gouvernementaux alexandre
lukashenko en compagnie de son fils se
rend sur les lieux
dans son discours il remercie les
personnes présentes et accuse
l'opposition de vouloir déstabiliser le
pays
aujourd'hui la priorité de loukachenko
est de rétablir l'ordre dans le pays
afin de calmer la foule ce dernier admet
la possibilité de nouvelles élections
mais seulement
après un référendum sur la nouvelle
constitution son contenu ainsi que les
délais les baies sites restent encore
floues cependant au fur et à mesure que
la contestation s'essouffle la certitude
de loukachenko de rester dans le
fauteuil présidentiel augmente non je ne
démissionnerai pas tout à coup je
quitterais simplement ce poste lorsque
cela sera nécessaire pourquoi tout à
coup c'est dangereux
lukashenko pourra-t-il se maintenir au
pouvoir compte tenu de la pression
croissante de l'occident quels sont les
pays qui défendent activement l'idée de
nouvelles sanctions contre la
biélorussie et qui au contraire tendent
la main dead à loukachenko
comment ce dernier modifie t-il le cap
du pays à l'international
après les élections la réponse après la
pause
[Musique]
voici plus de trois mois que la
biélorussie traverse une période de
fortes turbulences
un interne des dizaines de milliers de
personnes continuent à descendre dans la
rue exigeant le départ d'alexandre
loukachenko
le premier et unique président de la
biélorussie depuis son indépendance ex
républiques de l'ancienne urss la
biélorussie obtient son indépendance le
25 août 1991 dans le contexte de
l'affaiblissement du pouvoir central
soviétique s'ouvre donc une période de
transition durant laquelle le pays est
dirigé par stanislav chouchkevitch
président du conseil suprême biélorusse
ardent défenseur de l'économie de marché
il prône la mise en place des réformes
libérales et entame une vague de
privatisations
à l'international il se rapproche de
l'occident mais tend les relations avec
moscou en arrière-plan
pourtant les positions de chouchkevitch
s'affaiblissent suite un rapport
présenté en décembre 1993 par alexandre
lukashenko président du comité
anti-corruption au parlement biélorusse
il accuse le pouvoir bélarusse d'être
responsable d'une corruption endémique
qui a paralysé le pays
le rapport produit l'effet d'une bombe
informationnel qui a abouti à la
démission de chouchkevitch en janvier
deux mois plus tard la constitution
biélorusse est adopté pour la première
fois un introduit le poste du président
qui devra désormais assumer le rôle du
chef de l'état à la surprise générale
l'élection présidentielle fixé pour
l'été 1994 et remportée par alexandre
lukashenko s'opposant temps candidat
proche du peuple
il promet des changements radicaux en
interne et le rapprochement avec la
russie
une fois installé dans le siège
présidentiel le cash nko'o joint le
geste à la parole
la privatisation et ralentit les prix
deviennent contrôlées par l'état
côté diplomatique minsk se tourne peu à
peu vers moscou
en 1995 la russie la biélorussie et le
kazakhstan sint un accord sur la
création de l'union douanière et quatre
ans plus tard l'état de l'union russie
biélorussie est annoncée parmi d'autres
mesures figurent l'attribution du statut
officiel à la langue russe
pourtant les relations avec les pays
occidentaux se dégrade au fur et à
mesure que loukachenko renforce son
pouvoir présidentiel en 2004 un autre
coup est porté aux relations avec les
pays occidentaux
il s'agit d'un référendum qui élimine
toute limite du nombre de mandats
quelques jours après le plébiscite
george bush signe l'acte sur la
démocratie en biélorussie qui suspend
toute aide financière à minsk et qui
avance un nombre d'exigences au pouvoir
biélorusse comme la tenue d'élection
présidentielle sous contrôle de l'eau et
c'est eux
à partir des années 2000 les relations
avec la russie connaissent elles aussi
difficulté
la formation de l'état de l'union
russie-biélorussie patine faute d'un
accord sur les conditions d'intégration
à cela s'ajoutent les désaccords sur le
prix du gaz qui aboutissent en 2004 à
une brève interruption des livraisons du
gaz russe à la biélorussie
trois ans plus tard nouveau scandale
cette fois au sujet du pétrole la russie
surtaxe ses exportations d'or noir en
provenance de la biélorussie provoquant
une réaction négative de la biélorussie
en 2009 éclate la guerre laitière moscou
barre l'accès à son marché du lait
biélorusse qui ne correspond pas aux
nouvelles normes sur fond de tensions
avec la russie la biélorussie change peu
à peu le ton à l'égard de l'occident
en 2008 celle opposant le plus connu à
l'époque alexandre cazoulines libéré de
prison
la normalisation tant attendu semble
commencer
2009 la biélorussie est un des six pays
inclus dans le programme du partenariat
oriental visant à approfondir des
relations entre bruxelles et son
voisinage oriental
pourtant la tension reprend de nouveau
la suite de l'élection présidentielle de
2010 en cause la dispersion des
manifestations d'opposition et
l'emprisonnement de plusieurs candidats
c'est à partir de là que la ligne
politique multivectorielle de
loukachenko prend de plus en plus de
nouveaux contours tout en coopérant avec
la russie le président biélorusse
parvient quand même à démarrer la
normalisation avec l'occident
en 2015 les états unis annonce la levée
partielle de leur sanction lieu et le
canada suivent le pas début 2020
bruxelles et minent ce que ton d'accord
sur la simplification du régime des
visas en même temps les relations avec
pékin se renforce de plus en plus entre
2009 et 2019 les investissements chinois
en biélorussie ont été multipliées par
deux sens à cela s'ajoute la coopération
dans de nombreux domaines dont le
commerce et la défense cette politique
multivectorielle et mise à l'épreuve
avec le lancement de la campagne
présidentielle biélorusse en 2020
l'arrestation de candidats d'opposition
et de leurs partisans provoque une
farouche critique de la part de l'ue eux
est des états unis
pourtant les relations avec la russie et
la chine qui reconnaissent les résultats
du scrutin reste stable la situation
effervescente en biélorussie ne cesse
d'agiter la communauté internationale et
surtout les plus proches voisins du pays
la pologne et la lituanie
ils sont parmi les premiers de l'union
européenne à se prononcer sur la
situation et se positionne immédiatement
du côté de l'opposition nous devons
soutenir le peuple biélorusse dans sa
quête de liberté
ce soutien a évoqué par le dirigeant
polonais commence vite à prendre forme
le 14 août
sony annonce une enveloppe de 11
millions d'euros dettes aux biélorusses
le but est de financer l'installation
des opposants en pologne d'offrir des
bourses aux jeunes réfugiés de soutenir
les médias d'opposition et les ong bio
le ru la lituanie offre aussi des
bourses ainsi que des soins gratuits
pour les manifestants blessés les deux
pays devienne une terre promise pour les
opposants trois figures de position se
trouve en ce moment en pologne et
svetlana chicanos callas seront dès le
11 août en lituanie et s'entretient avec
le président lituanien en ligne et les
autorités du pays en face à face et en
septembre le parlement lituanien
reconnaît tikhonov sky a comme
présidente biélorussie dans une
résolution la veille l'opposante est
reçu en pologne un protocole digne d'une
visite d'un chef d'état accueil par le
premier ministre marche de solidarité à
ses côtés à varsovie et inauguration du
nouveau centre de soutien à l'opposition
dit maison bio l'heureux et cet
activisme de l'europe orientale fini par
persuader l'union européenne bruxelles a
déjà adopté deux volets de sanctions
personnelles 55 personnes sont touchées
au total dont alexandre lukashenko et
ses proches
le troisième volet est aussi prévue
celui ci visera des entreprises
biélorusses ce qui pourrait endommager
l'économie du pays de plus dès août
bruxelles des blogs 53 millions d'euros
pour le peuple biélorusse dont 2
millions aux victimes de répressions et
un million aux activistes et aux médias
indépendants
cette dernière enveloppe devrait
d'ailleurs croître jusqu'à 24 millions
d'euros fin septembre bruxelles rejoint
les états unis le canada et le
royaume-uni et refuse officiellement de
reconnaître alexandre loukachenko en
tant que président
l'union européenne affirme une nouvelle
fois que l'élection présidentielle tenue
le 9 août en biélorussie n'a été ni
libres ni régulière l'union européenne
ne reconnais pas les résultats falsifiés
en se distanciant de loukachenko l'union
européenne multiplie les contacts avec
sa rivale pendant l'automne ce fait la
nati canaux ce qu'aia rencontre une
multitude de dirigeants européens
emmanuel macron angela merkel et
d'autres l'opposante est aussi accueilli
dans les institutions de l'union
européenne et les reçus par le président
du parlement européen et est invité au
sommet des ministres des affaires
étrangères tout cela au plus grand dam
de loukachenko qui défie la pression de
bruxelles et critique son ingérence
en réponse lukashenko sanctionne les
diplomates de l'union européenne réduit
la présence diplomatique polonaise et
lituanienne ou encore menace de
perturber le trafic commercial depuis
l'union européenne
en fermant la frontière biélorusse de
plus en plus isolé le dirigeant de misc
cherche le soutien à l'est bien sûr fond
de pressions externes sans précédent la
biélorussie a profité d'un vaste soutien
de la part de nos alliés traditionnels
en ce temps difficiles c'est la russie
la chine et d'autres pays qui nous ont
apporté leur aide et leur soutien les
plus tangibles hilton il dit cela
pourquoi la chine d août elle met son
poids diplomatique derrière loukachenko
si jean ping est le premier à le
féliciter de sa réélection depuis le
biélorusse multiplie les rencontres avec
les diplomates chinois qui s'alignent
complètement sur sa position derrière
cet appui
l'intérêt économique pour pékin miss est
un relais commercial important sur la
voie vers l'europe
du coup la chine est de plus en plus
présente elle construit par exemple en
parc industriel et une usine
d'automobiles près de minsk au total
pékin a investi presque 2 milliards de
dollars en biélorussie depuis 2010
pourtant elle reste loin derrière la
russie
les investissements de moscou sont
quatre fois supérieurs à ceux de pékin
sur la même période
la russie est aussi le plus grand
créancier de minsk son premier
partenaire commercial et sa principale
source d'énergie
très bon marché ces faveurs s'explique
par un lien très spécial entre moscou et
minsk
c'est par la biélorussie que passe la
plupart du trafic commercial entre la
russie et l'europe aussi bien que les
pipeline gazier et pétrolier plus qu'une
alliance régionale depuis la fin des
années 90 les deux états forme l'état de
l'union russie biélorussie un projet
visant la création d'une confédération
malgré les efforts de moscou sa
réalisation patine toujours
du coup la dîmière poutine promet le
sujet à l'ordre du jour en félicitant
lukashenko après l'élection
j'escompte que votre activité au niveau
de l'état contribuera au développement
ultérieur des relations russo biélorusse
mutuellement bénéfique dans tous les
domaines au renforcement de la
coopération dans le cadre de l'état de
l'union
ce message semble être entendu à minsk
début septembre moscou informe du
progrès des discussions sur la fusion
économique russo biélorusses en même
temps son soutien à minsk devient réel
la russie annonce avoir formé une
réserve d'argent des forces de l'ordre
qui interviendront en biélorussie si
nécessaire peu après moscou approuvé un
prêt de 1,5 milliard de dollars pour
renflouer l'économie biélorusse plus
fidèles alliés de lukashenko la russie
peut-elle compter en retour sur sa
loyauté
car avant l'élection les relations
étaient au plus bas
une trentaine de russes étaient arrêtés
en biélorussie minsk les accusant de
préparer des opérations de sabotage pour
déstabiliser le pays en période
électorale
après le scrutin la bonne entente
semblait être revenu dans les relations
entre moscou et minsk
mais depuis que les protestations se
calment en biélorussie lukashenko temps
à changer encore une fois de ton en
novembre il parle même de diplomatie
multidirectionnel au lieu de direction
russe jusqu'où tiendra la patience du
kremlin face à l'allier volatile
pour mieux comprendre l'avenir
biélorusse nous revenons aux verts
pierre laurent écrivain et spécialiste
du monde post soviétique et de la russie
monsieur laurin parlons maintenant de
l'aspect géopolitique de la question
biélorusse pensez vous que les visions
complètement différente sur ce problème
vont encore aggraver les tensions entre
l'union européenne et la russie
il est très difficile d'aggraver quelque
chose qui est à ce point la dégradation
est telle qu'on voit mal à part une
guerre nucléaire ce qui pourrait ternir
encore les relations
là la situation en biélorussie apparaît
d'une manière très nuancée pour les
occidentaux
visiblement il n'envisage pas une
épreuve de force ni avec la build up
biélorussie ni a fortiori avec moscou
c'est que ce qu'ils ont fait jusqu'à
présent c'est protester c'est d'une
manière très ferme
par exemple lorsque macron président
emmanuel macron dit que monsieur
lukashenko doit quitter le pouvoir ce
sont les expressions fortes qui sont
soutenus par l'ensemble des pays
occidentaux
le problème c'est que ça ne mène nulle
part
s'il n'y a pas des mesures fermes pour
aller dans ce sens ça ne win mais ce qui
est intéressant c'est qu'avec tout ce
qui se passe même avec tout ce qui se
passe loukachenko dit vouloir poursuivre
sa politique multivectorielle pensez
vous qu'ils réussissent dans ces
conditions à restaurer ses relations
avec l'union européenne et peut-être
même avec les états unis avec la
nouvelle administration
ça c'est le grand le grand mystère de
loukachenko
il est très clair que il pense il pense
très clairement que ce qui lui a réussi
pendant vingt ans il peut continuer de
le faire c'est à dire jouer sur les deux
tableaux
le problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui les
complète complètement discréditée en
occident qu'est ce qui pourrait le
remettre en selle et bien d'une part
qu'il quitte la présidence ce qu'il
envisage de faire d'ailleurs qu'il
partage le pouvoir avec
une partie de l'opposition du moins
qu'il fasse semblant de le partager
pendant quelques temps avant que des
réformes plus poussée soit avancé d'ici
quelques années mais en tout cas faire
participer l'opposition à au jeu du
pouvoir
vraisemblablement par l'intermédiaire
d'élections législatives où l'opposition
eurent une large part et où le pourrait
contribuer au jeu du pouvoir mais ça
pour les occidentaux c'est parfait ils
ne demandent que cela que lukashenko
sent l'ail de la présidence et 1 c'est
un impératif pour mais en revanche qu'il
reste comme je ne sais pas premier
ministre ou autre ou une autorité
supérieure qui dirait la politique sans
forcément y participer avec des
personnalités reconnues par l'occident
comme pouvant jouer un rôle
et bien pour ça c'est pour cela les
occidentaux seraient prêts à travailler
avec une biélorussie ou lukashenko
resterait une personnalité dominante
donc parlons maintenant de son voisin de
l'est que pensez vous de l'état de
l'union russie biélorussie
est ce une utopie ou verra-t-on un
progrès sur ce terrain là ah ça c'est
très compliqué parce que pendant depuis
23 ans que l'accord d'union a été conclu
il n'y a pas eu réellement d'avancée du
point de vue politique
en revanche il ya des avancées sérieuses
du point de vue économique en
particulier dans le dialogue entre les
régions entre les régions russes et les
régions biélorusse
il ya beaucoup d'accords qui sont signés
il y a eu une volonté progressive
d'intégration économique entre les deux
pays et elle cela fonctionne lentement
mais cela fonctionne en revanche du
point de vue politique il est absolument
impossible de créer une union
russie-biélorussie digne de ce nom
tout simplement parce que cela
apparaîtrait aux yeux de la planète
entière et des biélorusses yeux
m comme un rattachement de la
biélorussie à la russie le seul moyen
éventuelle de faire admettre une union
politique
si l'on met de côté bien entendu la
partie économique qui rend la chose
assez improbable ce serait que le
président de la future union mais avec
un pouvoir réel
ce soit un biélorusse et ça je ne pense
pas que la russie soit capable de
l'accepter aujourd'hui merci beaucoup
pierre le rein je rappelle pierre laurin
écrivain et spécialiste du monde post
soviétique était là aujourd'hui avec
nous merci encore pour votre analyse
cette partie là n'est pas encore
terminée la semaine prochaine une
nouvelle partie vous attend avec
d'autres pions sur l'échiquier mondial
à bientôt sur rt france
[Musique]